la ville attire vous êtes là bonjour
content de vous voir et vous venez faire
un jeu on va jouer au jeu des mines
on va me met des choses sont d'accord
venez les enfants venez venez on fait
deux équipes une à droite et une âme à
gauche
casimir du jeu avec nous qu'est ce que
c'est que ce qui se passe quel jeu on va
animer des chansons qu'ils aimaient un
méchant fonds minimale et avec l'autre
équipe malige il bon d'accord gilles
j'ai eu le loisir avance un petit peu et
minutes et chansons
regardez bien non pas y aller oui bon
alors une réponse compris frères jacques
c'est ça ces départs jagot signaux 3g à
nous en faire retrouver
peu importe mois vas-y recommencer
alors des réponses fatale trois quarts
et ce n'est pas ses chansons trois
quarts et chamarrée pour cela qu'elle
est roussel ravir le sien vous cherchez
alors c'est ça chantait nouveau petit
peu au delà les succès de la série
véhicules fermage entend le rêve tu
crois tu crois que ça
owen sur le pont d'avignon casimir tuent
nos fermiers moi tu domines une chanson
allez casimiro mille vols à la tire
mieux que l'on approche on a la même
chanson tenez bon tenez par exemple
voilà on est passé voilà faut pas faire
de bruit la casimir la mine doit pas
faire bien dans le silence le plus
complet bon florence 30 bouton temarii
30 tombe pas dans la sauce et ça n'est
pas coupé
est ce que c'est ça mais florence qu'il
y trompons pas un mari trompé dans la
soupe c'est ça non non il part ça j'ai
mangé du vendredi à tanger c'est pas ça
c'est que c'est pas difficile à trouver
on est on est dans l'îlot z'enfants
quasi mais qu'est ce qui fait selon nous
il mange pas du bobby rouillard et la
même chanson alors oui je sais j'ai eu
ma chance en vous la connaissez la
chanson la chanson que j'aime et vous la
connaissez à l'extrême
[Musique]
avec une chanson
imagination 100 m
notre vie tranquille
je sois y est terrorisée je suis le
monstre qui périt
m
la couleur orange
non
[Musique]
et pour moi
je sais jouer de la musique
je souligne l esma tirs camille si
j'aime la glace au sang chaud
seb ou moi même endroit avec une chanson
un peu d'imagination
tu
mais nous dans notre it is aussi du
bonheur tranquille
[Musique]
c'est qu'on peut rencontrer
ne soyez pas terrorisé
je suis le monstre qui fait rire
j'ai une malle magique réunis je mange
bluebeam pour le gamin j'ai vu la ville
de qoqani
6 mai
mais gare à toi c'est mon droit avec une
chance
un peu de magie noire
autre issue
découverte
soyez
et rossi
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
[Musique]
casimir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]